From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ike Sriskandarajah filling in for Ira Glass.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是代班伊拉·格拉斯的艾克·斯里斯坎达拉贾。
Calm bodies, calm voices, calm minds.
平静的身体，平静的声音，平静的心灵。
It's calm, for now, in the second grade classroom in Cold Spring, New York. There are about a dozen kids sitting close around a rug, knees touching.
在纽约州冷泉市的这间二年级教室里，此刻很安静。大约有十二个孩子围着一块地毯坐在一起，膝盖挨着膝盖。
Let's listen to the sound of the bell.
让我们听听铃声。
[BELL DINGS]
[铃声响起]
These kids are getting ready for a very particular lesson. It's one that I heard about from my coworker, Nadia. I asked my wife, who's a teacher, and she knew about it, too. And a friend of mine says he still remembers this lesson from when he was in third grade. It stuck with him. And I wanted to see this rite of passage play out for myself.
这些孩子们正准备上一堂非常特别的课。这是我从同事纳迪亚那里听说的。我问过我身为老师的妻子，她也知道这节课。我的一位朋友说，他至今还记得三年级时上的这节课。这事一直印在他的脑海里。我想亲眼看看这个成长礼是如何进行的。
All right, so the game we're going to play today is called What's in the Box? Have you played this game before?
好了，我们今天要玩的游戏叫“盒子里有什么？”你们以前玩过这个游戏吗？
Yes.
玩过。
It's a guessing game that's kind of famous here. Ms. Maria, the director of the Manitou School, holds up a white cardboard box about the size of a shoebox.
这是一个在这里很有名的猜谜游戏。马尼图学校的校长玛丽亚女士举起一个鞋盒大小的白色纸板盒。
So I have put something in this box, and you can't break it by shaking it. So you can shake it. You can move it. And we're going to pass the box around, and you're going to tell me what you think is in the box, OK?
我在盒子里放了点东西，你们不能通过摇晃把它弄坏。所以你们可以摇一摇。你们可以动一动。我们要把盒子传下去，你们要告诉我你们觉得盒子里是什么，好吗？
The kids seem amused. They want to try. She passes the box to the child on her left. The kid shakes it a little.
孩子们看起来很感兴趣。他们想试一试。她把盒子传给了左边的孩子。那个孩子轻轻摇了摇。
[RATTLING]
[嘎嘎声]
Uh, LEGOs.
呃，乐高积木。
Uh, a stapler?
呃，订书机？
Hmm.
嗯。
Uh, maybe marbles and-- marbles and balls.
呃，也许是弹珠和——弹珠和球。
Marbles and balls. Hmm.
弹珠和球。嗯。
As the box makes it around the 13 students, strategies start to emerge. One thoughtful little girl in purple glasses and snow boots shakes it real hard.
当盒子传到第13个学生手中时，策略开始出现了。一个戴着紫色眼镜、穿着雪地靴的可爱小女孩用力摇晃着盒子。
[RATTLING]
[嘎嘎声]
That doesn't get her any closer. The next time around, she takes off her own beaded necklace, shakes that close to her ears. Then she closes her eyes and shakes the box.
这没让她离真相更近。下一轮时，她摘下自己的串珠项链，在耳边晃了晃。然后她闭上眼睛，摇了摇盒子。
Yeah, they're both this-- they're kind of-- OK, definitely not what I thought.
是啊，它们都是这个——有点像——好吧，绝对不是我想的那样。
The rattles are different. Nobody has gotten it. Feels like it's time to bring in a dedicated professional in the answers-getting business, and the kids allow it.
摇晃的声音各不相同。没有人猜对。我觉得是时候请一位专门从事获取答案的专业人士出场了，孩子们也同意了。
Can I shake the box? You guys don't mind?
我可以摇一下盒子吗？你们不介意吧？
So I pick up the box. And they're right. It's about the weight of a toy, maybe the size of a fist or two, with smaller things rattling inside that object. Eureka!
于是我拿起了盒子。他们说得对。它的重量大约像个玩具，大概是一个或两个拳头那么大，里面有较小的东西在晃动。尤里卡！
OK, um, is it, like, a toy car with gumballs in it?
好的，嗯，它是那种装了口香糖的玩具车吗？
That's a really good guess.
这真是个很好的猜测。
But not good enough. Three times around the class, and nobody has guessed it. At this point, the kids are done. They're ready to find out. And that's when Ms. Maria does something the kids do not see coming.
但还不够好。在班里传了三圈，没人猜对。到目前为止，孩子们已经尽力了。他们准备好知道答案了。就在这时，玛丽亚女士做了一件孩子们意想不到的事情。
All right. Cool. Well, thank you for playing.
好了。酷。谢谢你们参与游戏。
Can you show it to us?
你能给我们看看吗？
I didn't say I was going to tell you what it was.
我没说我要告诉你们那是什么。
What? Please!
什么？拜托！
'Cause the game is about guessing. It's not about knowing.
因为游戏的目的在于猜测。而不是在于知晓。
She doesn't tell them. She was never going to. Ms. Maria takes the box away. And the kids are stunned. No more tries? No answer? That's it? They're not sure what to make of it.
她没有告诉他们。她从没打算告诉。玛丽亚女士把盒子收走了。孩子们惊呆了。没有更多尝试了？没有答案？就这样？他们不知道该怎么办。
Now, if hearing this makes you mad, if you're thinking, hey, that is not what school is about-- school's about finding answers to your questions-- Ms. Maria agrees. But she thinks this is important to learn, too. She wants them to learn how to endure the discomfort of not knowing. She's trying to prepare these kids for life, and that's the case she makes to them.
现在，如果听到这个让你生气，如果你在想，嘿，学校不该是这样的——学校是为了找到问题的答案——玛丽亚女士也同意。但她认为这也是需要学习的重要一课。她希望他们学会如何忍受“不知道”的不适感。她试图让这些孩子为生活做好准备，这就是她给出的理由。
And sometimes we all have things that we can't know sometimes because Ms. Maria won't open the box, but more often because it's just impossible to know. Like, your parents can't tell you certain things, or you can't get into somebody else's head, or you just can't know the reason for why something happened. So learning to live with that discomfort of not knowing is a really important thing. And that's part of what we were practicing here today.
有时我们都会遇到无法知道的事情，有时是因为玛丽亚女士不肯打开盒子，但更多时候是因为根本不可能知道。比如，你的父母不能告诉你某些事情，或者你无法进入别人的大脑，或者你只是无法得知某件事发生的原因。所以学会带着那种不知道的不适感生活是一件非常重要的事情。这正是我们今天在这里练习的一部分。
Sure, but the box is right there. It's just behind Ms. Maria on the floor. The answer is inside, just like all the other answers that powerful forces in our world are withholding from us. These kids and this journalist aren't having it. Ms. Maria's worthy lesson is overcome by a much stronger human impulse-- the desire to know what's in the box.
当然，但盒子就在那里。它就在地板上玛丽亚女士的身后。答案就在里面，就像我们世界上那些强大的力量对我们隐瞒的所有其他答案一样。这些孩子和这位记者可不接受这个。玛丽亚女士有意义的课程被一种更强烈的人性冲动所克服——想知道盒子里到底有什么的欲望。
We want to know what it is!
我们想知道那是什么！
Is it important, what's in the box?
盒子里装的东西很重要吗？
Yes!
重要！
Otherwise it'll keep us wondering, and I don't like mysteries!
不然我们会一直好奇下去，我不喜欢谜团！
Why would you keep wondering?
你为什么要一直好奇下去？
Because I want-- 'cause I would want to know what it is.
因为我想——因为我想知道那是什么。
No, we don't want. We need!
不，我们不是想。我们需要！
Oh, you need to know what it is.
哦，你们需要知道那是什么。
Need!
需要！
Yeah!
是啊！
We need to know!
我们需要知道！
And I get sick when I'm wondering.
而且一想到这个我就难受。
You get sick?
你感到难受？
And I don't like surprises.
而且我不喜欢惊喜。
I'm allergic to wondering. I'm allergic to wondering!
我对好奇过敏。我对好奇过敏！
Ms. Maria tries to bring the class back from the brink of anaphylactic shock. They talk about techniques to deal with the discomfort. They stand up and try to shake their body loose of the tension.
玛丽亚女士试图将全班从过敏性休克的边缘拉回来。他们谈论了处理这种不适的方法。他们站起来，试图摇晃身体以摆脱紧张感。
Do you feel better--
你们感觉好点了吗——
No.
没有。
--having shaken it off like a duck? No?
——像鸭子一样抖掉它之后？没有？
No.
没有。
No?
没有吗？
We feel better when you open the box!
你打开盒子我们才会感觉好点！
OK.
好吧。
Apparently, this is not an uncommon reaction. Ms. Maria told me years ago, she remembers when an entire class worked together to steal the box. The most trustworthy kids told her there was a plumbing emergency in the girls' bathroom, while another classmate snuck into the office Ocean's Eleven style. The heist was foiled, and then the box was moved to a secure location. And just earlier today, Ms. Maria was showing some of the teachers the mystery box before class. They made their guesses. And then she caught one of them trying to sneak a peek. The mystery, it can get to you not only if you're seven, but especially if you're seven. These kids, they see the future, an inscrutable world of infinite, unanswerable questions, and they say, no.
显然，这并非罕见的反应。玛丽亚女士几年前告诉我，她记得有一次全班同学联手去偷那个盒子。最值得信赖的孩子告诉她女厕所发生了管道紧急情况，而另一位同学则像《十一罗汉》那样潜入办公室。偷窃计划失败了，盒子随后被转移到了一个安全地点。就在今天早些时候，玛丽亚女士在上课前给一些老师看了神秘盒子。他们也做出了猜测。然后她抓到其中一个人试图偷看。如果你七岁，神秘感会折磨你，如果你是七岁，尤其如此。这些孩子，他们看到了未来，一个充满无限、无法回答的问题的神秘世界，他们说，不。
You're going to leave us wondering for the rest of our lives!
你要让我们在余生中一直好奇下去吗！
For the rest of your life?
在你的余生里？
Yes.
是的。
(CHANTING) What is it? What is it? What is it? What is it?
（齐声喊）那是什么？那是什么？那是什么？那是什么？
Ms. Maria is just leading this lesson. The regular classroom teacher wants to have kids who aren't freaking out and distracted the rest of the day. She would love this to end. So in a shocking turn of events, Ms. Maria caves to the mystery.
玛丽亚女士只是在引导这节课。普通的任课老师希望孩子们在剩下的一天里不要惊慌失措、心不在焉。她很想让这一切结束。于是，在令人震惊的转折中，玛丽亚女士向神秘感屈服了。
You're going to feel better when I open the box?
我打开盒子你们会感觉好点吗？
Yes.
是的。
OK. Here we go. This is the big reveal.
好的。我们要开始了。这是揭晓时刻。
She opens the box and shows that kids what's inside.
她打开盒子，向孩子们展示了里面的东西。
[SHOUTING]
[尖叫声]
Oh, my gosh. I would never have guessed.
天哪。我永远也猜不到。
But you? You can wait a little longer, right? Today, we'll hear people who stare at the giant question mark and plunge themselves deep into the unknown. What lies on the other side? You want to know? Do you really want to know what's in the box? Stay with us.
那你呢？你可以再等一会儿，对吧？今天，我们将听到那些盯着巨大的问号并深入未知世界的人的故事。另一边是什么？你想知道吗？你真的想知道盒子里是什么吗？留下来跟我们一起探索。
It's This American Life. Today's show, I Hate Mysteries. Act One, The Masta Blasta Digging Up Mount Shasta. That Hole is Deep 'Cause it Hasta Be.
这里是《美国生活》。今天的节目主题是“我讨厌谜团”。第一幕，挖掘沙斯塔山的巨坑。那洞深得有理由。
A while back, filmmaker Elijah Sullivan decided he was going to get to the bottom of a very strange event that happened in his hometown. Timber workers going through a national forest found an incredibly deep hole in the ground. Nobody could tell who had dug it or why or what they were looking for. Everyone in town had a theory, and some of those theories were really wild.
不久前，电影制作人伊莱贾·沙利文决定一探他家乡发生的非常奇怪的事件。在国家森林中穿行的木材工人在地上发现了一个深不可测的洞。没人能说出是谁挖的，为什么要挖，或者他们在寻找什么。镇上的每个人都有自己的理论，其中一些理论非常疯狂。
Elijah could not stop thinking about this hole. He'd been working on a documentary about it for about nine years, when someone got in touch with him who claimed to be one of the diggers. Here's Elijah.
伊莱贾无法停止思考这个洞。他为一部关于此事的纪录片工作了大约九年，这时有人联系他，自称是挖掘者之一。下面是伊莱贾的讲述。
His name was Brett. He said that depending on certain circumstances, like the statute of limitations, he was open to talking. He'd told pieces of the story before over beers. So I got him a beer, an old one from the fridge.
他的名字叫布雷特。他说，根据某些情况，比如诉讼时效，他愿意谈一谈。他以前喝酒时讲过故事的片段。所以我给他买了一瓶啤酒，冰箱里陈年的那种。
Does that still taste good? It's been in my fridge for three years.
那还能喝吗？它在我的冰箱里放了三年了。
I'm not afraid of a skunky beer, man.
伙计，我不怕变质的啤酒。
OK. Do you feel like launching into the story now?
好吧。你现在想开始讲这个故事了吗？
Yeah. Yeah.
是的。是的。
You want to start?
你想开始吗？
Yes, sir. All right, ready?
是的，长官。好的，准备好了吗？
Yes.
是的。
All right.
好的。
[CLACK]
[咔哒声]
For the next two hours or so, over a skunky beer, Brett told me his tale, the story I'd been waiting so long to hear, the story of the hole. It started in 2009, right after the Great Recession. Brett was just out of high school, living in Northern California and looking for work. As a kid, he said, he had never really fit in and had been kind of heading down a bad path.
接下来的两个小时左右，在变质的啤酒陪伴下，布雷特告诉我他的经历，我等待已久的故事，那个洞的故事。它始于2009年，大衰退之后。布雷特刚高中毕业，住在北加州寻找工作。他说，作为一个孩子，他从未真正融入群体，一直在走下坡路。
But he loved the outdoors. He'd worked for the California Conservation Corps and later trained to fight forest fires, which he was excited about, but his crew wasn't getting called up. He spent months looking for other jobs. Then he came across this listing on a message board.
但他热爱户外活动。他曾为加州保育团工作，后来受训去扑灭森林火灾，他对此感到兴奋，但他的团队没有被征召。他花了几个月时间寻找其他工作。然后他在公告板上看到了这个招聘信息。
And I looked, and there was a job opening. And it said, building a fence line in Mount Shasta. So I called the number, and a guy answers. And he goes, how old are you? And I tell him. I'm like, I'm like 19. He's like, oosh. Do you have your own tools, your own gear, gloves, boots? And I'm like, yeah. He goes, how fast can you be in Mount Shasta? And I'm like, well, I'm in Redding. I can make it in, like, 45 minutes, around there.
我看了一下，有一个职位空缺。上面写着，在沙斯塔山修筑围栏线。所以我拨打了那个号码，有人接听了。他问，你多大了？我告诉他。我说，我19岁。他说，哦。你有自己的工具、装备、手套、靴子吗？我说，有的。他说，你多快能到沙斯塔山？我说，我在雷丁。我大约45分钟左右能到那儿。
And he says, OK, go to this hotel, and a guy is going to meet you in the lobby. He'll give you a room. You'll meet up with the work crew in the morning and then go out and build this fence. And I'm like, all right, cool. Sounds good. So I put the last $40 I had to my name in my gas tank and drove my truck up to Mount Shasta.
他说，好，去这家旅馆，会有人在大厅见你。他会给你一个房间。明天早上你和工作组汇合，然后出去建这个围栏。我说，好的，太酷了。听起来不错。所以我把身上最后40美元加进油箱，开着我的卡车去了沙斯塔山。
Mount Shasta is this 14,000-foot, snow-capped stratovolcano near the Oregon border, with a small town nestled at its base. I've lived there basically my whole life. Brett arrived in the evening, pulling into a hotel in Mount Shasta City, right off of the freeway. As promised, there was a guy waiting for him. He seemed like the foreman of a crew.
沙斯塔山是一座海拔14000英尺、白雪皑皑的层状火山，靠近俄勒冈州边界，山脚下坐落着一个小镇。我基本上一直住在那儿。布雷特傍晚抵达，开进了沙斯塔山市的一家旅馆，就在高速公路旁。正如承诺的那样，有人在等他。那人看起来像是团队的领班。
And I think he was-- he had to have been around late 20s maybe, like 27, younger guy, in shape, covered in tattoos, very forward, very disciplined. And he just walked out, and he was wearing basketball shorts and flip-flops. And he goes, here's your key. This is your room. Meet the guys in the parking lot at this time in the morning. And I'm like, OK.
我想他一定在20多岁末期，可能27岁左右，年轻，身材健壮，满身纹身，非常直率，纪律严明。他径直走了出来，穿着篮球短裤和人字拖。他说，这是你的钥匙。这是你的房间。明天早上在这个时间在停车场见大家。我说，好的。
Finally, a job. Not only a job, but it paid well, and it got him out of Redding. They even gave him his own hotel room and a per diem.
终于有工作了。不仅有工作，报酬还不错，而且让他离开了雷丁。他们甚至给了他自己的酒店房间和每日津贴。
The next morning, I wake up. There's a van. And everyone's got milk jugs of water and stuff like that. And I meet up with them, and they're all bullshitting. I can tell they've been doing it for a little while, but I didn't know how long. And so I get in this van with these complete strangers, and we start driving up towards the mountain. And I remember driving backroads. And then we pull over in the middle of nowhere, and there's a trail at the tree line. And I get out, and we start walking. And I'm like, where are we going? We're building a fence.
第二天早上，我醒了。有一辆货车。每个人都拿着牛奶罐装的水之类东西。我见到他们，他们都在闲聊。我看得出他们已经干了一阵子，但我不知道多久。于是我上了这辆载满陌生人的货车，开始朝山上开。我记得开了乡间小路。然后我们在荒郊野外停下来，树线处有一条小路。我下车，开始走路。我说，我们要去哪儿？我们不是去建围栏吗？
So we start walking and walking and walking. And eventually I'm like, all right, guys, where's the fence? And I get laughed at. And I'm like, what's going on? Like, come on. And they're like, they told you a fence? And I'm like, yeah, yeah, I can string a fence. And they go, that's funny. Yeah, I got told I was putting a barn up. And another guy said something else, and another guy said something else. And I'm like, OK, now I'm far from home. I'm walking what feels like a couple miles down this trail into the wilderness with guys I don't know. And they're laughing at me, telling me I've been lied to about why I'm here. And that's when we got up on the hole.
于是我们开始走啊走啊走。最后我说，好吧，伙计们，围栏在哪里？他们嘲笑我。我说，到底怎么回事？得了吧。他们说，他们告诉你建围栏？我说，是啊，我能架起围栏。他们说，真逗。是啊，有人告诉我我是去盖个谷仓。另一个人说了别的，又一个人说了别的。我说，好吧，现在我离家很远了。我和我不认识的人走在感觉有几英里长的小径上深入荒野。他们嘲笑我，告诉我我被骗了。就在那时，我们来到了那个洞口。
The hole. The mouth of it was enormous, at least 10 by 12 feet. And it was deep, like a vertical mineshaft without any wooden beams holding it up, just sheer walls. Off to one side was a huge pile of dirt. Above, there was a steel cable with a pulley strung between trees. A few feet down was a boulder the size of a small car sitting on a ledge, and then a ladder leading down into the darkness.
那个洞。洞口非常大，至少10乘12英尺。而且很深，像一个垂直的矿井，没有任何木梁支撑，全是陡峭的墙壁。旁边有一堆巨大的泥土。上方，树木之间架着一条钢缆，上面连着一个滑轮。几英尺下方的壁架上坐着一块小汽车大小的巨石，然后是一架通往黑暗的梯子。
I remember looking in the hole, and everybody's getting ready. And I'm asking, what's going on? And they're like, we're digging. And I'm like, for what? And he's like, well, we don't exactly know. We were told if we found something weird, that we pull it out, and we were going to give it to Joseph.
我记得看向洞里，大家都在准备。我问，发生了什么？他们说，我们在挖。我说，挖什么？他说，嗯，我们不太清楚。他们告诉我们如果发现什么奇怪的东西，就把它拉出来，我们要把它交给约瑟夫。
Joseph was the guy running everything. Brett said he looked like a flatlander, meaning not from the mountains.
约瑟夫是负责人。布雷特说他看起来像个外地人，意思是不是从山上来的。
And he completely stood out. 'Cause all of us were blue collar workers, and we're in boots, jeans, cut-up shirts. And he was in a full suit, had dress shoes, full suit, up to the nines. And he walked that trail with us every single day, completely dressed.
他完全与众不同。因为我们都是蓝领工人，穿着靴子、牛仔裤、破烂的衬衫。而他穿着全套西装，皮鞋，打扮得一丝不苟。他每天都穿着那身衣服和我们一起走那条小路。
Somehow, all this weirdness-- the guy in the suit, being lied to, digging for something mysterious-- Brett says he just kind of went with it, maybe because he was surrounded by adults who had accepted it. He told me he didn't want to be the young guy asking too many questions. And also, he needed the money.
不知何故，所有这些怪事——穿西装的人，被骗，为了某种神秘的东西挖掘——布雷特说他只是随大流了，也许是因为他周围的成年人都接受了这一切。他告诉我他不想做那个问太多问题的年轻人。而且，他需要钱。
Workers disappeared down the hole to work in pairs. They used pickaxes to loosen dirt and fill 5-gallon buckets. Brett was told to stand at the edge of the hole and to hoist the buckets up. A plunge into the hole seemed likely to prove fatal, so Brett tethered himself to a tree, just in case. The simplicity of the work was satisfying, even validating. He'd been on trail crews before, so he knew more about this kind of work than most guys. For example, before Brett got there, the crew had run into a boulder in the hole and hadn't known what to do.
工人们成双成对地消失在洞里工作。他们用镐松土，装满5加仑的桶。布雷特被告知站在洞口负责提桶。掉进洞里很可能是致命的，所以布雷特把自己系在一棵树上，以防万一。这种工作的简单性令人满意，甚至具有肯定意义。他以前参加过小径清理工作，所以他比大多数人更了解这种工作。例如，在布雷特到达之前，团队在洞里遇到了块巨石，不知道该怎么办。
The main boulder, they had dug around at one point. And I remember asking, why didn't you go through it? And them looking at me kind of weird, and they're like, well, how would we go through it? We've tried. I'm like, well, how did you try? Well, we brought a battery-powered jackhammer up here, and I'm like, how'd you-- in the wheelbarrows and carrying. And I'm like, no, no, no, no. You drill into it using leaves and feathers, and you split the rock in multiple sections and it'll break. And once his eyes lit up, it was like, OK, this young kid might know a few things.
那块主要巨石，他们曾一度绕着挖。我记得我问过，为什么你们不穿过它？他们看我的眼神有点奇怪，说，好吧，我们怎么穿过它？我们试过了。我说，你们是怎么试的？嗯，我们带了个电池驱动的电钻上来，我说，你们怎么——在独轮车里带着工具。我说，不，不，不。你用叶子和羽毛钻进去，然后把岩石分成几部分，它就会碎了。当他的眼睛亮起来时，就像是，好的，这个年轻人可能懂点东西。
Anytime anyone had an idea to improve their digging operation, Joseph, the guy in the suit running things, would head down the trail back into town for supplies. He had a credit card, which Brett called the magic card.
每当有人提出改进挖掘操作的想法时，负责这一切的穿西装的约瑟夫就会走下小径回城里买补给。他有一张信用卡，布雷特称之为魔术卡。
Joseph was like, I've been given this card. Whatever we need to make this happen, I will swipe it. And he was swiping that card, and infinite money to make this happen.
约瑟夫说，我得到了这张卡。为了实现目标，无论需要什么，我都会刷卡。他一直在刷那张卡，有无限的钱来完成这件事。
Brett quickly fell into a routine. He would ride up the mountain every morning, tie himself to the tree, pull buckets all day, then go back to his hotel. The others would go to the bar or to get food, and Brett would just go to the gas station or back to his room. Then they would start again in the morning. Week after week, with every bucket he pulled, he watched the hole get deeper. One day, it was finally Brett's turn to work in the hole.
布雷特很快进入了常规。他每天早上骑车上山，把自己系在树上，整天拉桶，然后回旅馆。其他人会去酒吧或买东西吃，而布雷特只是去加油站或回房间。然后他们早上又重新开始。一周又一周，随着他拉起的每一桶土，他看着洞变得越来越深。有一天，终于轮到布雷特在洞里工作了。
They kept that shaft very square. I mean, you could look up at the top of the hole and see the iron veins when the sun would come over the top. It was beautiful. When the sun would come over and the light would shine into the hole, you could see iron veins all the way down the sides.
他们把那个井保持得非常方正。我的意思是，你可以抬头看向洞顶，当太阳升起时，能看到铁矿脉。太美了。当阳光照进洞里，你可以看到沿壁向下的所有铁矿脉。
Maybe the adventure made it easier not to think about the bigger questions, like what they were doing there. Speaking up might have meant going back to Redding. At least he was outside.
也许这种冒险经历让人更容易不去思考更大的问题，比如他们为什么在那儿。说出来可能意味着回到雷丁。至少他在户外。
Like, nature's my thing. I'm peaceful. I'm calm. I'm happy. And maybe that was how I justified part of it. It was good for me to be up on that mountain every day. And maybe that's what-- it wasn't just being naive. It was overlooking circumstances, because I was out there every day.
就像，大自然是我的最爱。我很平静。我很冷静。我很开心。也许这就是我为部分行为辩解的方式。每天上山对我来说是件好事。也许这就是——那不仅仅是天真。那是忽略了环境，因为我每天都在那儿。
Going up and down the trail, it was like the Seven Dwarves. We were laughing, tools over our shoulders, jugs of water. They had milk jugs. I had this little Smartwater bottle that I'd carry with me, and laughing. It was constant. Like, somebody would say something down the line. You'd be walking and turn your head back, and get back in the conversation, get up there.
走在上下山的小路上，就像七个小矮人一样。我们在笑，工具扛在肩上，带着水壶。他们有牛奶桶。我有个小智能水瓶带在身上，都在笑。那是一种常态。就像，队伍里有人会说些什么。你走着走着回头，又回到谈话中，然后上山。
And I started making friends a little bit with people. There were a couple guys in the crew that were cool to me, kind of took me under the wing-- cooler, older guys. And for me, at that time, trying to find my place in the world, and a bunch of older guys being like, this kid's the kid-- and I was like, I'm in, let's do it. That praise, at that time in my life, went a long ways for me. So that smoothed over the edges quite a bit in the beginning. But it didn't last forever.
我开始和人们交朋友。团队里有几个家伙对我很好，把我带在身边——很酷的年长家伙。对于我当时试图在世界上找到自己的位置来说，一群年长的人说，这孩子是个好苗子——我当时觉得，我加入，干吧。那种赞美，在我人生的那个阶段，对我帮助很大。所以这在开始时掩盖了很多矛盾。但它并没有持续永远。
As the summer wore on, the adventure wore off. The deeper they went, the harder it was to dig. Sometimes the hole would fill up with bees. As it got deeper, they had to add things to reach the bottom. There was a rope to get into the hole, then a chain leading to two ladders tied together. Brett occasionally would help with the digging, but mostly, he was above ground, pulling the buckets up, which meant he had a bunch of time to be around Joseph.
随着夏天过去，冒险的乐趣也消失了。挖得越深，挖掘就越困难。有时洞里会充满蜜蜂。随着洞变得更深，他们必须增加工具来够到底部。有一根绳子进入洞中，然后是一条连着两架系在一起的梯子的链子。布雷特偶尔会帮忙挖掘，但大部分时间，他在地面上，把桶提上来，这意味着他有很多时间在约瑟夫身边。
I had a feeling that Joseph was not the one calling the shots. He was the representative for somebody. And I would ask questions a little bit on who was running this, and very circular conversation-- was not getting a lot of answers. Joseph used to get these phone calls. We would go a couple days without finding anything, and then he'd get a call on his cell phone, an old flip phone back then. And you could just tell his demeanor would change.
我有一种感觉，约瑟夫并不是真正做主的人。他是某人的代表。我会问一些关于谁在运行这件事的问题，对话非常循环——没得到多少答案。约瑟夫过去常接到这些电话。我们会几天找不到任何东西，然后他会在手机上接到电话，那是当年的旧翻盖手机。你一眼就能看出他的神态会变。
The phone would ring. He'd pull the phone out, take a breath, walk like 10 feet out in the woods, and he'd have this phone call. And you'd see him in the bushes. He's not on the trail. He's standing in bushes, in nice leather flat shoes and in a suit, kind of pacing around in circles a little bit, kicking the ground, and lots of nodding. And he'd come back and take a deep breath and then, OK, guys, let's keep going. It's like, we haven't stopped. So there was definitely some type of driving force that he was getting from the organization he worked with. It was almost a "don't come back unless you find it."
电话响了。他拿出手机，深吸一口气，走到森林里约10英尺的地方，接电话。你可以在灌木丛中看到他。他不在小径上。他站在灌木丛中，穿着漂亮的皮鞋和西装，有点踱步，踢着地面，不停地点头。然后他走回来深吸一口气，好的，伙计们，继续。就像，我们从来没停过。所以肯定有一种来自他工作的组织推动力量。几乎就像是“如果不找到它就别回来”。
And we started getting worried, especially when we knew how important this thing that we didn't know what it was, was to them, that what happens when we find it? When the older guys started getting scared, that's when it started coming out in me. Because there was moments where Joseph wasn't necessarily totally with us walking up the trail, and that's when we started having these conversations.
我们开始担心，特别是当我们知道那个我们不知道是什么的东西对他们有多重要时，当我们找到它时会发生什么？当年长的家伙开始感到害怕时，那才在我身上体现出来。因为有几次约瑟夫并没有完全和我们一起走上小径，就在那时我们开始有了这些对话。
There had been so much time to think, to imagine where this was going, what they were doing, why they were doing it. Brett wondered if the people funding it had some mining license that was about to expire. That would explain why they were in a rush, but not all the other weirdness.
有太多的时间思考，想象这一切要走向何方，他们在做什么，为什么要这么做。布雷特想知道资助它的人是否有什么即将到期的采矿许可证。这可以解释为什么他们如此匆忙，但无法解释其他所有怪异之处。
Like, whatever we're doing is shady, at least. I don't even know if the word "illegal" was thrown around, but this is shady. And that's when I found out a couple of guys were like, look, I'm going to bring a gun up with me. I remember one of them was like, dude, if we find it, what if they kick us in the hole?
比如，无论我们在做什么，至少是阴暗的。我不确定“非法”这个词是否被提到，但这很阴暗。就在那时我发现几个家伙说，看，我要带把枪去。我记得其中一个说，伙计，如果我们找到了，万一他们把我们踢进洞里怎么办？
I'm standing next to that hole all day long. There's already guys in it. There's a gigantic boulder on the edge. I think it was a chain was holding it in place, maybe. All of us were in the hole, around the hole. It would have been very easy to push us in.
我整天站在那个洞边上。里面已经有人了。边缘有一块巨大的岩石。我想是一条链子把它固定在原位，可能。我们所有人都在洞里或洞周围。把我们推下去太容易了。
Brett started to think about bailing. I asked Brett why he hadn't before. Part of it was that he just wanted to know what they were digging for, the answer to the mystery. Now he wasn't so sure he wanted to know. Anytime they found anything that might be something, it was carefully inspected by a guy named Cokey.
布雷特开始考虑退出。我问布雷特为什么之前没退。部分原因是他只是想知道他们在挖什么，想知道谜题的答案。现在他不确定自己是否还想知道了。每当他们发现任何可能是东西的东西时，都会由一个叫科基的家伙仔细检查。
Brett said Cokey was an old Navy vet, more of a blue collar guy like the other workers, and reminded Brett of his grandfather. Everything they found in the hole went to Cokey. And at some point, they started finding these rocks, kind of sizable, maybe twice as big as a basketball. And they all looked similar. Cokey would crack them open. They weren't allowed to look.
布雷特说科基是一位老海军退伍军人，更像其他工人的蓝领，让布雷特想起他的祖父。他们在洞里发现的一切都交给了科基。在某个时候，他们开始发现这些岩石，相当大，大约是篮球的两倍。而且它们看起来很相似。科基会把它们撬开。他们不被允许看。
And then towards the end, it was like we were finding more of it. And then, [SIGHS] I can't remember if it was mostly one day we pulled a bunch out, but I just remember pulling buckets and hearing dudes yell and then trying to get them out, handing them off. They get pulled over to that little platform built up by the dirt we had pulled out. And Cokey had turned his back to us. We kind of looked away. He split a couple of them.
然后在最后，就像是我们发现了更多。然后，[叹气]我不记得是不是大部分都是一天挖出来的，但我只记得拉桶和听到人们大喊，然后试着把它们弄出来，递出去。它们被拉到那块由我们挖出的泥土堆成的平地上。科基背对着我们。我们有点移开了视线。他劈开了其中的几个。
Brett says, for the first time, Joseph and Cokey's faces lit up.
布雷特说，这是第一次，约瑟夫和科基的脸亮了起来。
And I think-- I think they sent us home. And we never called it early.
我想——我想他们让我们回家了。我们从来没有提前收工过。
Brett went back to his hotel.
布雷特回到了他的酒店。
What just happened?
刚刚发生了什么？
I thought I was coming back the next day. I just was like, if we found what they're looking for, why are we leaving? So that's why I went back to my hotel room, laying in bed, really like, what's going on? Have I got myself into something? And that's when I got the phone call in the middle of the night.
我以为我第二天会回来的。我当时想，如果我们找到了他们要找的东西，为什么我们还要走？所以这就是我回到酒店房间，躺在床上，真的在想，到底发生了什么？我卷进了什么事情？就在那时，我在半夜接到了电话。
It was the crew lead. He said he would give Brett $200 to drive up the mountain with him and gather all the rocks they had found in the hole, just the two of them right now. Brett agreed. He told me it was stupid of him to go, but he thought, let's get this done, and then the job will be over with.
是领班。他说他会给布雷特200美元，让他和自己一起开车上山，把他们在洞里找到的所有石头收集起来，就他们俩现在去。布雷特同意了。他告诉我他去那儿很蠢，但他想，做完这件事，工作就结束了。
We loaded up my truck and went up the mountain in the middle of the night. It would have been around midnight. I parked my truck at the bottom. We busted out one Rubbermaid trash can. And he looked at me, and he was like, this is what we're going to do. We're going to put this trash can in between us. We're going to take our belts off, and we're going to loop it through the handles. And each one of us is going to put our belt on our shoulder, and we'll take as many down as we can.
我们装上我的卡车，在半夜上了山。那时大约是午夜。我把车停在底部。我们拿出一个橡胶女仆垃圾桶。他看着我，说，这就是我们要做的。我们把这个垃圾桶放在我们中间。我们脱掉腰带，把它穿过把手。我们要把腰带背在肩上，能带多少就带多少。
We hiked up there, and that's what we did. We went to the pile of rocks that were ranging from here to about here, and we'd put as many in there as we could. And we'd do the shoulder test. Pick it up if we can get it off the ground. And if we could, it was like, all right, buddy, let's go. And we went down the trail. Loaded my truck, came back up, did it again, over and over and over again, aching. And we kept a pace. And we made lap after lap, I mean, just bleeding sweat, coming down that mountain.
我们徒步走上去，这就是我们做的。我们走到那堆从这里到那里的岩石旁，尽可能多地装进去。然后我们做肩测。如果我们能把它抬起来。如果可以，那就，好了，伙计，走吧。我们走下小径。装好我的卡车，再回来，又做了一次，一遍又一遍，非常痛苦。我们保持着速度。我们一圈又一圈，我的意思是，满身大汗，走下那座山。
And by the time we were done, my back of my truck was full. I had an old '89 Chevy. And I flattened my leafs and I blew out my brakes on the way down. I barely made it down that mountain without losing control at the bottom.
当我们做完时，我的卡车后座装满了。我有一辆旧的89年雪佛兰。我的钢板弹簧被压平了，下山时我的刹车爆了。我差点没在山脚失去控制，勉强开了下来。
The two of them drove the rocks to a rental storage place. Joseph was there waiting. So was a U-Haul truck.
两人把石头开到了一个租赁仓库。约瑟夫在那里等着。还有一辆U-Haul卡车。
Then it was really solidified that this is done. Because when they cracked the back, and I saw they had wooden-framed the inside for one little cradle for each rock-- and they were ready to go. I don't remember the drivers getting out. I don't know who was driving them. And we picked those rocks up. We put them in there.
然后这一切真的结束了。因为当他们撬开后门，我看到他们已经为每一块石头在里面钉了木架——他们准备出发了。我不记得司机下车。我不知道是谁在开车。我们把那些石头捡起来。我们放进车里。
And Joseph shook my hand, and he was happy. He was happy. The stress was off. Whatever stress was on him, he had accomplished it. And then I had heard-- I either overheard or he told me that they're going to Florida. And they left.
约瑟夫握了握我的手，他很高兴。他很高兴。压力消失了。无论他承受什么压力，他都完成了。然后我听说——要么是我无意中听到的，要么是他告诉我的，他们要去佛罗里达。然后他们离开了。
Brett didn't realize until an hour or two later that they hadn't paid him the $200.
布雷特一个或两个小时后才意识到他们没付给他那200美元。
Later that summer, timber workers stumbled across the hole while marking trees. It was in a national forest, and it's illegal to dig without a permit. The hole looked to be about 60 feet deep. I spoke to one ranger who said it was the damnedest thing he had ever seen in his Forest Service career.
那年夏天晚些时候，伐木工人在标记树木时偶然发现了这个洞。它在国家森林里，没有许可证挖掘是非法的。这个洞看起来大约60英尺深。我采访了一位护林员，她说这是她在林务局职业生涯中见过的最见鬼的事情。
The Mount Shasta Herald ran an article in October-- "US Forest Service investigating hole on Mount Shasta." The article had a photo of the hole. At the bottom was Brett's bottle of Smartwater. Gawkers kept gathering to look at the hole, so the Forest Service filled it back in. By the time I saw the spot a few years later, the trail had faded, but the trees still had scars from the cable. And there was a 5-gallon bucket lying around. Every time I visited, it was in a different spot. And one day, it was gone.
《沙斯塔山先驱报》在十月刊登了一篇文章——“美国林务局调查沙斯塔山上的洞”。文章里有一张洞的照片。底部是布雷特的智能水瓶。围观者不断聚集来看这个洞，所以林务局把它填上了。几年后当我看到那个地方时，小径已经消失了，但树上还有电缆造成的伤痕。还有一桶5加仑的桶躺在那儿。每次我去，它都在不同的地方。有一天，它不见了。
At the time, all we had was wild speculation. There were three plausible theories. The first was gold. I heard rumors about an underground river of gold, maybe a treasure map purchased in a bar. But I talked to the geology instructor at the local community college who pointed out that Mount Shasta was actually a volcano, and volcanoes don't have gold in them, so that theory was out.
当时，我们所有的只是疯狂的猜测。有三个看似合理的理论。第一个是黄金。我听说过关于地下黄金河的传闻，也许是在酒吧买的藏宝图。但我咨询了当地社区学院的地质学讲师，他指出沙斯塔山实际上是一座火山，火山里没有金子，所以那个理论被排除了。
The second was Native American artifacts. Unfortunately, this is incredibly common in the US. I asked some state police officers and experts on investigating looters, but nobody had heard of looters digging 60 feet straight down. So the looting theory was out, too.
第二个是美洲原住民文物。不幸的是，这在美国非常普遍。我咨询了一些州警官和调查盗墓者的专家，但没人听说过盗墓者会直直向下挖60英尺。所以盗墓理论也被排除了。
That leaves the third theory. It's something we locals discuss the most. But Brett isn't from here. He didn't hear about it until midway through the dig, when he went home for the weekend. He was drinking beer with some friends on their porch and telling them about the job he was doing on Mount Shasta.
这留下了第三个理论。这是我们当地人讨论最多的。但布雷特不是本地人。他直到挖掘过程中期才听说这件事，当时他周末回了家。他和朋友在门廊上喝啤酒，讲述他在沙斯塔山做的工作。
And I started getting into the details of it, and everybody gets kind of quieter and quieter. And I hear this noise from above me because it was a multi-story. I think it was a two-story apartment complex. And I hear, oh, and then footsteps moving. And then I hear it running through one of the apartment complexes, coming down the stairs. And it was this really spun-out woman that came out holding a book.
我开始谈论细节，大家都变得越来越安静。我听到上方传来噪音，因为这是多层建筑。我想那是一个两层公寓大楼。我听到，哦，然后是脚步声。然后我听到它穿过一个公寓单元，走下楼梯。那是一个非常疯狂的女人，手里拿着一本书走出来。
So she goes, sorry, I've been listening to everything you've been saying, but this is what's going on. And she hands me this book about Mount Shasta and starts going through the pages and finds this chapter on Saint Germain. And she goes, do you know what this is? And I'm like, no. And she's like, OK. And I started reading it. And that's when it clicked.
所以她说，抱歉，我一直在听你们说的每一件事，但这才是真正发生的事情。她递给我这本关于沙斯塔山的书，并开始翻页，找到了关于圣日耳曼的一章。她说，你知道这是什么吗？我说，不知道。她说，好的。我开始读它。就在那时我明白了。
The Count of Saint Germain was a real historical figure from the 1700s. Some people believed he was immortal. An American mining engineer named Guy Ballard claimed he met Saint Germain in 1930, here, on the mountain. Ballard said he was hiking, and Saint Germain appeared multiple times, once offering him a crystal cup filled with a clear, sparkling liquid. This encounter inspired Ballard and his wife, Edna, to found a New Age religion called The I AM Activity. That's two words, "I AM," all caps. Ballard died in 1939, but The I AM Activity still has members all over the world.
圣日耳曼伯爵是1700年代真实的历史人物。有些人相信他不朽。一位名叫盖伊·巴拉德的美国矿业工程师声称他在1930年，就在这里，在山上遇到了圣日耳曼。巴拉德说他在徒步，圣日耳曼出现了多次，有一次递给他一个装满清澈闪亮液体的水晶杯。这次邂逅启发了巴拉德和他的妻子埃德娜创立了一个名为“I AM活动”的新时代宗教。那两个词，“I AM”，全大写。巴拉德死于1939年，但“I AM活动”在世界各地仍有成员。
Around the same time Guy Ballard says he met Saint Germain, a book was published called Lemuria, Lost Continent of the Pacific. It had a chapter that claimed there was a hidden city under Mount Shasta, inhabited by some of the last remaining members of a sunken continent. People have been looking for the entrance of the city ever since.
就在盖伊·巴拉德声称遇到圣日耳曼的同时，一本名为《利莫里亚，失落的太平洋大陆》的书出版了。它有一个章节声称在沙斯塔山下有一个隐藏的城市，居住着沉没大陆最后幸存的成员。从那时起人们一直在寻找城市的入口。
The book is not related to Saint Germain, but added to the myth of the mountain. Not everyone comes to Mount Shasta for Lemuria or Saint Germain. Some are just looking for purpose or community. My parents were seekers. They moved us to Mount Shasta from Massachusetts when I was six. So to me, this made total sense, that the hole had something to do with all these stories.
这本书与圣日耳曼无关，但增加了山的神秘感。并非每个人来到沙斯塔山都是为了利莫里亚或圣日耳曼。有些人只是在寻找目标或社区。我的父母是寻求者。我六岁时他们把我们从马萨诸塞州搬到了沙斯塔山。所以对我来说，这说得通，这个洞与所有这些故事有关。
Eventually, I tracked down and spoke to three other people who had helped dig the hole. One of them said they'd been paid by a believer in Saint Germain and described what they were looking for as gold plutonium. He said something about it being used to power Lemurian cities.
最终，我找到了并采访了其他三个参与挖洞的人。其中一个人说他们是被一个圣日耳曼的信徒雇佣的，并将他们寻找的东西描述为黄金钚。他说了一些关于它被用来为利莫里亚城市供电的事情。
The other two diggers mentioned uranium. None of it made sense, but it always pointed back to the stories about the mountain. I did try to contact The I AM Activity a couple of times, but the person who answered the phone told me that my message probably wouldn't be returned. It wasn't.
另外两个挖掘者提到了铀。这一切都说不通，但它总是指向关于这座山的故事。我确实试图联系过“I AM活动”几次，但接电话的人告诉我，我的留言可能不会得到回复。确实没有回复。
After that last scary night on the mountain, Brett drove straight home to his mom's in Redding.
在山上那个恐怖的夜晚之后，布雷特直接开车回家到了雷丁母亲那里。
I just couldn't believe all this had happened. And then, plus, I hadn't slept. And I got back. I hadn't been telling my mom what I'd been doing. I told her I was working. And I remember I called my dad. My mom is a sweetheart, and she's always been the one that's let me run a little crazy, but has been like my stone.
我简直不敢相信所有这一切都发生了。而且，加上我一直没睡觉。我回去了。我没告诉母亲我一直在做什么。我告诉她我在工作。我记得我给父亲打了电话。我母亲是个甜心，一直以来她都是那个让我有点疯狂，但一直是我基石的人。
And my dad is a lot like me. And I started telling him what I had been doing, and he got upset. And I remember that was the final thing where it was like-- when he was like, you cannot do stuff like that. You have to realize what you just did, and I'm very happy you're safe. But that could have gone very bad. And you can no longer go through life being naive like that.
我父亲和我有很多相似之处。我开始告诉他我一直在做的事，他很生气。我记得那是最后一件事，他说——他说，你不能做那样的事。你必须意识到你刚才做了什么，我很高兴你是安全的。但这可能会演变成非常坏的结果。你不能再像那样天真地生活了。
And I was happy. I remember I picked up my skateboard, and I met with my friends and spent a week off-gassing, just letting all that go. And then once you're out of that mindset, you're not around those people, then you start realizing, what were we really doing? What did I let someone talk me into? Am I liable for anything?
我很高兴。我记得我拿起了滑板，和朋友们聚在一起，花了一周时间放松，把所有这一切都抛在脑后。一旦你摆脱了那种心态，不在那些人身边，你就开始意识到，我们到底在做什么？我让谁说服我干这种事？我需要负什么责任吗？
And that's why it was really chilling when I got that phone call. I can't remember how long it was, so I'm trying to think. It was after the summer. And maybe it was around the fall. And I had a call came through that I didn't recognize the number and answered it, and I recognized the voice instantly. That stoic, man-of-few-words voice telling me, we're going back. And I remember being like, good luck, because I'm not going.
这就是为什么我接到那个电话时真的很冷。我不记得过了多久，我在想。那是在夏天之后。也许是秋天左右。我接到了一个我不认识的号码的电话，我瞬间认出了那个声音。那个冷静的、话语不多的人声告诉我，我们要回去了。我记得当时说，祝你们好运，因为我不去了。
After that, Brett joined the military and rarely comes back to the area. Like many before him, he had come down from the mountain with a wild story. He still thinks about it.
在那之后，布雷特参了军，很少回到那个地区。像许多人之前一样，他从山上下来，带着一个疯狂的故事。他至今还会想到它。
There are times when I'm out elk hunting or something. I'm breaking brush off trail, and I'll see-- I'll come up over a hill, and you'll see a false summit or a gully in the ground or something like that. And you start seeing-- my brain will put shit together. When the landscape's just right and the sun hits, I'm on the right slope, and, yeah, things in the environment and the landscapes are piecing together, and I can picture it again. That'll be with me forever.
有时当我在猎鹿之类的活动时。我正在小径外穿过灌木丛，我会看到——我会爬上一座山，你会看到假山顶或地里的冲沟之类的东西。你开始看到——我的大脑会把事情拼凑起来。当风景刚刚好，阳光照过来，我在正确的斜坡上，是的，环境和景观中的事物拼凑在一起，我又可以想象它了。那将永远伴随着我。
If you met Joseph again, do you have anything you'd want to say to him?
如果你再次见到约瑟夫，你有什么想对他说的吗？
Man, I'd ask why. I'd take everything I just said, and I'm like, am I right? Is this what you were doing? Is this the motivation? Was it this church that is all the things, these little details that I put together from things you've said, things I've heard, things I saw? What weren't you telling me? And then the next thing is, what did we find? Because I saw it. It didn't seem like something that was worth doing what we did. Am I wrong?
伙计，我会问为什么。我会拿出我刚才说的一切，我会问，我是对的吗？这就是你在做的吗？这就是动机吗？是这个教会吗，那些从你说的话、我听到的事、我看到的事拼凑出来的小细节？有什么是你没告诉我的？接下来就是，我们找到了什么？因为我看到了。这似乎不值我们所做的一切。我错了吗？
I wondered about those things, too. A strange final footnote to this story is that the Forest Service did find the person they think is responsible for the hole. Their local Forest Service law enforcement officer, Carmen Kinch, told me she did a bunch of sleuthing and figured out what hotel the workers had been staying in, and from the hotel, the name of the person who had paid for the rooms. She said the person said they had been looking for gold and paid a fine, but couldn't give me the person's name.
我也在想这些事。这个故事的一个奇怪的最后脚注是，林务局确实找到了他们认为对那个洞负责的人。他们当地的林务局执法官卡门·金奇告诉我，她做了一堆调查，弄清楚了工人们住的是哪家旅馆，并从旅馆那里得知了付房费的人的名字。她说那个人说他们一直在寻找黄金，并付了罚款，但不能给我那个人的名字。
And without a name, I haven't been able to find any court records, though I tried for years. These days, I'm not looking so hard anymore. I've had to accept that you just don't always get to the bottom of everything. Sometimes, when you open the box, inside, there's just another box.
没有名字，我几年以来一直没能找到任何法庭记录。这些天，我不再那么费力寻找了。我不得不接受并不是所有事情都能查个水落石出。有时，当你打开盒子，里面只是另一个盒子。
Elijah Sullivan. His documentary is called The Hole Story. It's showing at film festivals, and he's looking for a distributor. Special thanks to Benjamin Bombard, who told us about the documentary.
伊莱贾·沙利文。他的纪录片叫《洞的故事》。它正在电影节上放映，他正在寻找发行商。特别感谢本杰明·邦巴德，他告诉了我们这部纪录片。
When we were putting together today's show, we heard from lots of people who have mysteries in their lives that they can't get out of their head. And one of them came from Lauren Peterson, who read a story with a mystery in it that stuck with her.
在整理今天的节目时，我们收到了很多人的来信，他们生活中有一些无法忘怀的谜团。其中一个来自劳伦·彼得森，她读了一个带有谜团的故事，并深深印在了她脑海里。
So for years, I have been plagued by a New York Times article by Katie Weaver-- whose writing I love-- where she went to a glitter factory and toured the glitter factory.
多年来，我一直被凯蒂·韦弗写的一篇《纽约时报》文章所困扰——我非常喜欢她的写作——她去了闪粉工厂并参观了闪粉工厂。
And while Katie was on this tour, the glitter factory spokesperson said, you'll never guess which industry buys the most glitter, and then wouldn't tell her. No matter how many times the reporter asked, the spokesperson said, we can never tell you.
当凯蒂参观时，闪粉工厂的发言人说，你永远猜不到哪个行业购买了最多的闪粉，然后就不告诉她了。无论记者问了多少次，发言人总是说，我们永远不能告诉你。
And for years, I have been desperate to know, who is this secret consumer of glitter? What could it possibly be?
多年来，我一直极度渴望知道，谁是这个神秘的闪粉消费者？这到底是什么？
You need to know.
你需要知道。
You need to know. And I think the piece came out around Christmas, I want to say. So this was also the number one topic of conversation among my family and extended family for that entire Christmas. Everything we thought of, it either didn't seem like it would be big enough, or there was no reason that they wouldn't want us to know. Like, if it was cosmetics, why couldn't they say that on the record? So it can't be that. But is it, like, why is your toothpaste so sparkly? Could it be-- is it the fluoride or is it glitter from the glitter factory?
你需要知道。我想那篇文章是在圣诞节前后出的，我想说是。所以这也是整个圣诞节期间我的家人和大家庭中讨论的头号话题。我们想到的一切，要么看起来不够大，要么没有理由让他们不想让我们知道。比如，如果是化妆品，为什么他们不能在记录中说出来？所以不可能是那样。但是，比如，为什么你的牙膏这么闪亮？会是——是因为氟化物还是来自闪粉工厂的闪粉？
Her wife thought it could be the US military. She'd heard they'd dropped metallic material from planes sometimes to scramble radar.
她的妻子认为可能是美国军方。她听说他们有时会从飞机上投放金属材料来干扰雷达。
How many people were in on this?
有多少人参与了这件事？
My mom is one of eight. So that's a big family on that side. We definitely talked about it. Plus, some friends. I have a group text where, every once in a while, one of us will put forward a new theory to this day. So I'd say we're looking at 20 people who I'm regularly bringing this up to. I once brought it up to someone who I was sitting next to on an airplane. I occasionally will just go back and look at the Reddit forums where people are trying to figure out the answer. What could it possibly be?
我母亲是八个兄弟姐妹之一。所以那一边是一个大家庭。我们确实谈论过它。另外，还有一些朋友。我有一个群聊，直到今天，我们偶尔会有人提出一个新的理论。所以我说可能有20个人我经常提起这件事。我曾经在飞机上把它提给坐在我旁边的人。我偶尔会回去查看Reddit论坛，看看人们是否试图找出答案。这到底可能是什么？
And what if I told you we have the answer?
如果我告诉你我们有答案了呢？
My jaw dropped. [LAUGHS] How did you find out?
我的下巴都要掉下来了。[笑]你是怎么发现的？
Would you just open your phone and type in the word "glitter mystery"?
你愿意打开手机输入“闪粉谜团”这个词吗？
Yes. Yes, I will-- and not for the first time, I might add. [LAUGHS] OK, when you google glitter mystery, the very first thing that comes up after the AI is, the mystery of the largest glitter purchaser has been solved. [LAUGHS]
是的。是的，我会——而且我可以补充一下，这可不是第一次。[笑]好吧，当你搜索“闪粉谜团”时，在AI之后跳出的第一件事就是，“最大闪粉买家之谜已被解决”。[笑]
The post is a link to a 2019 podcast that broke the news of the mystery buyer. There's a long Reddit discussion about the answer. But somehow, Lauren had never seen it. So I told her.
那篇文章是一个链接到一个2019年的播客，报道了这个神秘买家的新闻。关于答案有一个很长的Reddit讨论。但不知何故，劳伦从来没见过。所以我告诉了她。
The largest buyer of glitter is boats.
最大的闪粉买家是船。
Boats?
船？
Yeah, boats. They use it for their paint.
是的，船。他们把它用于油漆。
Sparkly? I mean, I guess they are. Why don't they want us to know?
闪亮？我的意思是，我想它们确实是。为什么他们不想让我们知道？
I don't--
我不知道——
Why does it have to be a secret? They're not military-grade boats. They're just regular boats.
为什么非要保密？它们又不是军用船只。它们只是普通的船。
May I ask you, are you happy that you know?
我可以问你吗，你知道了以后开心吗？
No. Such a disappointing answer. And I kind of wish I still thought that the US military was glitter bombing other nations. [LAUGHS]
不。如此令人失望的答案。我有点希望我还认为美国军方在对其他国家进行闪粉轰炸。[笑]
Everything that glitters is not boat, but a lot of it is. Lauren was not the only person disappointed in the answer. On Reddit, there were even people who worked in the marine paint industry who knew they used lots of glitter, but they were also hoping the answer was something else. Mysteries are like that. Once you have the answer, the sparkle disappears.
所有闪闪发光的东西不一定是船，但很多确实是。劳伦并不是唯一对答案感到失望的人。在Reddit上，甚至有人在船舶漆工业工作，他们知道他们用了大量的闪粉，但他们也希望答案是别的。谜团就是这样。一旦你有了答案，那种闪烁感就消失了。
The biggest glitter buyer was originally uncovered by the podcast Endless Thread. We reached out to Glitter X, the company profiled in the New York Times story. They declined to confirm if their biggest buyer is boats. They are still committed to the mystery.
最大的闪粉买家最初是由播客《无尽线程》发现的。我们联系了《纽约时报》文章中提到的公司Glitter X。他们拒绝确认他们最大的买家是否是船。他们仍然致力于保持这个谜团。
Coming up, did we just become best friends, or am I being kidnapped? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，我们刚成为好朋友，还是我正在被绑架？来自芝加哥公共广播电台，一分钟后节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ike Sriskandarajah, sitting in for Ira Glass. Today, I Hate Mysteries-- stories of people grappling with the unknown that's right in front of them. Act Two, Who Are the People in Your Neighborhood? The mystery that I want solved most urgently right now is, what happens when the full force of the federal government arrives on my block? I happen to live in a neighborhood in New York City that is half foreign-born.
这里是《美国生活》。今天的节目，我讨厌谜团。第一幕，在那儿的人是谁？我现在最迫切想要解开的谜团是，当联邦政府的全部力量到达我的街区时会发生什么？我正好住在一个一半居民是外国出生的纽约市街区。
Given the national tour of Border Patrol, ICE, and sometimes the National Guard, it seems like they could come here. They just closed their operation late last week in Chicago, Operation Midway Blitz. According to DHS, they arrested 5,000 people in the Chicago area. Immigration arrests didn't stop after that. They're just not at the rate they've been at in the past two months.
考虑到边境巡逻队、移民海关执法局有时还有国民警卫队的全国巡回，看起来他们可能会到这里来。他们上周晚些时候在芝加哥结束了他们的行动，“中途闪电行动”。据国土安全部称，他们在芝加哥地区逮捕了5000人。移民逮捕并没有在那之后停止。只是不像过去两个月那样频繁了。
We can get some sense from videos on the news and social media about what happened in Chicago-- people dragged out of cars, chased into daycares, neighborhoods teargassed. But what is it really like to live in a neighborhood like that day to day? So we called one of our former colleagues, Michelle Navarro. She grew up on the southwest side of Chicago, a Mexican part of town. And she still lives there. Here's Michelle. She changed some of the names in this story.
我们可以从新闻和社交媒体的视频中了解到芝加哥发生了什么——人们被从车里拖出来，追进托儿所，社区被催泪瓦斯喷射。但在那样的社区里，日复一日地生活到底是什么样子？于是我们给以前的同事米歇尔·纳瓦罗打了电话。她在芝加哥西南部长大，那里是墨西哥人聚居区。她至今住在那儿。下面是米歇尔。她在故事中修改了一些名字。
I've been getting this question a lot. Friends from out of state have been hitting me up, asking me, are you good? They want to know what it's like here. They want to know if the videos and the things they've read are how it's actually playing out.
这个问题我一直被问到。外州的朋友一直在联系我，问我，你还好吗？他们想知道这里是什么样子。他们想知道视频和他们读到的东西是否就是现实中发生的情况。
I haven't known what to say. I had to go back through my phone to know what just happened, because it's been hard to remember. I've been scrolling back through my text messages, through the half-sentences I wrote in my Notes app, the videos I saved on my phone. I need them to remember my own life because I don't even know.
我不知道该说什么。我不得不翻看手机才能知道刚刚发生了什么，因为很难记住。我一直在翻看我的短信，翻看我在笔记应用中写的半句话，保存的视频。我需要它们来记住我自己的生活，因为我甚至都不知道。
They launched Operation Midway Blitz in early September. That is when they started to bounce between neighborhoods-- Back of the Yards, Brighton Park, Gage Park, Little Village, Pilsen, Little Village, and Back of the Yards again. In little over a week, more than 500 people were detained. It was a free-for-all, a purge. There's no other way to describe it.
他们在九月初启动了“中途闪电行动”。那时他们开始在社区之间蹦跶——后院、布莱顿公园、盖奇公园、小村庄、皮尔森、小村庄，然后又是后院。在不到一周的时间里，超过500人被拘留。这是一场乱斗，一场清洗。没别的词可以形容它。
And when they take people, they vanish. They're out as a family at Millennium Park on a Sunday. They're waiting for the bus, taking the trash out, selling tamales. Then men in ski masks and mismatched tactical gear appear. And then they're gone.
当他们抓人的时候，人们就消失了。他们周日作为家庭在千禧公园。他们等公交车、倒垃圾、卖塔马利。然后戴着滑雪面罩和不匹配战术装备的男人出现了。然后他们就消失了。
My phone is a catalog, an archive of how we tried to keep living our lives. This is what I found. Scrolling back to the early days to when they started grabbing people from the street, there's a text confirming my nail appointment at Jessica's Nail Spa, Wednesday, September 17, 2025, 5:30 PM. See you soon, Michelle Navarro.
我的手机是一个目录，一个我们如何尝试继续生活的档案。这是我找到的内容。回翻到他们开始在街上抓人的初期，有一条短信确认了我在Jessica美甲水疗中心的预约，2025年9月17日周三，下午5:30。很快见，米歇尔·纳瓦罗。
I remember that day. That weekend, I was hosting a party for my roommate's birthday. I'm used to being welcomed to the nail salon with laughter and loud Spanish love ballads. I'm a regular. They usually tease me. Let me guess-- red, square tip? But this time, when I approached the salon, and I pulled on the door to find it locked, I watched their heads lift in unison. I saw relief when they realized it was just me.
我记得那天。那个周末，我在为我室友的生日举办派对。我习惯了在美甲沙龙受到欢声笑语和高调西班牙情歌的欢迎。我是常客。他们通常会逗我。让我猜猜——红色，方指甲尖？但这一次，当我走近沙龙，拉开门发现它锁着，我看到他们的头同时抬了起来。当他们意识到只是我时，我看到了解脱。
I know all the women who work here. We usually ask each other about work, about boyfriends, about family. This time, we didn't. We waited, as we always do now, to see who was going to bring it up first. It was them. They told me they think about it all day. They heard ICE was spotted in the Marshalls parking lot that morning, about a block over, where they often leave their cars. It's where they must walk to after work.
我认识这里工作的所有女性。我们通常会问起对方工作、男朋友、家人的情况。这一次，我们没有。我们像现在一样等待，看谁会先提出来。是她们。她们告诉我，她们整天都在想这件事。她们听说那天早上有人在Marshall的停车场看到移民局，大约一个街区远，那是她们经常停放车辆的地方。那是她们下班后必须走过去的地方。
I asked my nail tech, Sara, about her daughter and her son in hopes of something lighter. She begins to tell me a story about her son's elementary school. She says that during class, kids could hear the screams of someone being taken right outside of the school building.
我问我的美甲师萨拉关于她女儿和儿子的情况，希望能聊点轻松的。她开始讲关于她儿子小学的故事。她说，上课时，孩子们能听到有人在学校建筑外被带走时的尖叫声。
The school administration later wrote to those parents that someone not connected to the school was detained outside by federal agents. They reassured parents that students would be safe in class, and that parents would be safe at drop-off and pick-up. But the next day, out of about 30 kids in her son's class, only three showed up. She stops filing my nails. She looks up at me. What do you think I should do? Should I send them to school?
学校管理部门后来写信告诉家长，有人与学校无关在外面被联邦特工拘留。他们向家长保证学生在课堂上会很安全，家长在送孩子和接孩子时也会安全。但第二天，她儿子班上大约30个孩子里，只有三个到了。她停止修剪我的指甲。她抬头看着我。你觉得我该怎么做？我应该让他们上学吗？
For that moment, I imagined she's my mother, that I am her eight-year-old son, seeing masked, militarized men taking her away. I tell her, if you're scared, don't take them. The following morning, while I'm getting ready for work, I wonder if she's dressing her children for school or if she plans to take my unqualified advice. It's all I can think of for the rest of the day.
那一刻，我幻想她是我的母亲，而我是她八岁的儿子，看着戴面具的军事化人员把她带走。我告诉她，如果你害怕，就别带他们去了。第二天早上，我在准备上班时，我想知道她是在给孩子穿校服准备上学，还是打算采纳我这种不负责任的建议。那天剩下的时间我满脑子想的都是这个。
The most surprising thing about masked men running around in your neighborhood and terrorizing your people is realizing that the world doesn't stop. You still have to clock in for your job. You still need groceries. You still have to make small talk.
社区里有戴面具的男人到处乱跑、恐吓你的人民，最令人惊讶的是意识到世界并没有停止。你仍然必须去打卡上班。你仍然需要杂货。你仍然必须进行闲聊。
Another text I found in my phone, with a guy from Hinge, October 22. He wants to get coffee in Pilsen this weekend, but we're having trouble finding a time that works. He works at a factory nearby. He texted me that ICE agents are outside his job, and he's covering for coworkers without papers. He keeps having to change the time. I tell him, no worries. He texts, they're just grabbing people and waiting for people to leave work, so now we're telling the night shift to stay home. I hate it here. We never met up that weekend.
我在手机里找到的另一条短信，来自Hinge上的一个家伙，10月22日。他想这周末在皮尔森喝咖啡，但我们很难找到合适的时间。他在附近的工厂工作。他发短信说移民局特工在他工作地点外面，他正在帮没有证件的同事掩护。他一直在改时间。我告诉他，不用担心。他发短信说，他们只是在抓人，等着人们下班，所以现在我们告诉夜班的人呆在家里。我讨厌这里。那个周末我们没见面。
Everyone is talking about rules, but there doesn't seem to be any. Our mayor, organizers, and legal advocates have said that ICE and Border Patrol can't do a number of things. They can't go on private property. They can't go on city property. They can't throw tear gas in our neighborhoods, right outside of people's homes. But they continue to do so.
每个人都在谈论规则，但似乎根本就没有规则。我们的市长、组织者和法律倡导者说移民局和边境巡逻队不能做很多事情。他们不能进私人财产。他们不能进城市财产。他们不能在我们的社区里，在人们的家门口扔催泪瓦斯。但他们继续这样做。
Four days after the start of this operation, they shoot and kill a man in Franklin Park. Not long after, just two miles from where I live, they shoot a woman five times. The Department of Homeland Security keeps talking about people who broke the law, who are here illegally, who committed crimes, but they target all of us, anyone who is Brown, anyone who speaks Spanish or just lives here.
行动开始四天后，他们在富兰克林公园开枪打死了一名男子。没过多久，离我住的地方只有两英里，他们开枪打了五次一名女子。国土安全部一直在谈论那些违了法、非法在这里、犯了罪的人，但他们针对的是我们所有人，任何棕色皮肤、任何说西班牙语或只是住在这里的人。
If you get picked up, you could spend a day or a week in detention. So we can't let people outside by themselves anymore. Even those of us with papers, with legal status, are on high alert. They roll up on us in parking lots, on people's front yards, outside of schools, and ask, are you from here? Are you from here?
如果你被抓走，你可能要在拘留所呆一天或一周。所以我们不能再让人们独自呆在外面了。即使我们这些有证件、有合法身份的人，也处于高度戒备状态。他们就在停车场、人们的前院、学校外面围住我们，问，你是这里的人吗？你是这里的人吗？
Other moments from my phone-- on October 4, there's a video from my friend, Bianca. We've all been friends since sixth grade. Bianca's a realtor now. She's in her car, in between showings. She says, guys, this is so sad. Families who I sold houses to last year are calling me now, asking me to put those same houses back in the market. They're heading back to Mexico. A home in the United States was a dream they finally realized. They were just crying of happiness not that long ago, she says. And now they have to let it go.
我手机里的其他瞬间——10月4日，来自我朋友比安卡的视频。我们从六年级起就是朋友。比安卡现在是房地产经纪人。她在车里，在带看房子的间隙。她说，伙计们，这太令人难过了。去年我卖给房子的家庭现在打电话给我，要求我把同样的房子放回市场。他们正回墨西哥去。在美国有一个家是他们终于实现的梦想。没多久前他们还因幸福而哭泣，她说。而现在他们不得不放弃。
October 25, an invite to Gabby's annual Halloween party. She called it A Halloween to Remember. After a few hours into the party, I look around and ask where Yazmin is. Gabby looks at me. Yazmin can't come out right now. Oh, shit, I forgot. She's undocumented. I felt so stupid. I felt so careless.
10月25日，加比年度万圣节派对的邀请。她叫它“一个难忘的万圣节”。派对进行了几个小时后，我环顾四周，问亚兹敏在哪里。加比看着我。亚兹敏现在不能出来。哦，该死，我忘了。她是无证件的。我感觉自己太蠢了。我感觉自己太大意了。
Before the end of the party, Gabby makes sure each guest leaves with a goodie bag, which contains two pieces of chocolate, Skittles, a whistle you can wear around your neck, and a small home-printed booklet instructing you on what to do when you spot ICE. Form a crowd. Stay loud, the cover says.
派对结束前，加比确保每个客人都带着一个礼包离开，里面有两块巧克力、彩虹糖、一个你可以戴在脖子上的哨子，以及一本小小的自制手册，指导你在看到移民局时该怎么做。形成人群。保持吵闹，封面写着。
Code 1, ICE nearby. Blow in a broken rhythm. Pre-pre-pre! This alerts the community that ICE agents are in the area. Code Red, blow in a continuous, steady rhythm when ICE is detaining someone. The last page reads, protect each other, always. Happy Halloween, I guess.
代码1，移民局在附近。用断断续续的节奏吹哨。哒-哒-哒！这提醒社区移民局特工在附近。代码红，在移民局拘留人时，以持续、稳定的节奏吹哨。最后一页写着，永远保护彼此。万圣节快乐，我想。
I look back at my call log. There's a list of calls in quick succession one day at 1:26 PM to my mom, and then to her neighbors. I remember exactly what these calls are. I'd seen a post that ICE was two blocks away from my parents' house. I called my mom. I know, she said. There was non-stop honking about 20 minutes ago. That's a thing now-- people honking to alert everyone that ICE is right here. And cars follow behind them until they can't.
我回头看通话记录。有一天下午1:26有一连串电话给母亲，然后是她的邻居。我清楚地记得这些电话是什么。我看到一个帖子说移民局离我父母家有两个街区远。我给母亲打了电话。我知道，她说。大约20分钟前一直不停地按喇叭。现在这成了一件事——人们按喇叭提醒每个人移民局就在这里。车辆跟在他们后面直到跟不上。
Where's Dad? I asked. He's working. My dad calls me later on his way home from work. I tell him our neighbors are safe. Then I say, Dad, you can't go to the swap meet anymore. The owner had said he wanted to keep people safe, but he didn't. More than 20 federal agents took 15 people. That's my dad's spot. It's where he goes for random parts and hardware. But I told him no more Swap-o-rama. He agreed he'd find a different place to do his shopping.
爸爸在哪里？我问。他在工作。爸爸后来在他下班回家的路上给我打电话。我告诉他邻居们很安全。然后我说，爸爸，你不能再去跳蚤市场了。老板说他想保护人们，但他没保护。超过20名联邦特工带走了15个人。那是爸爸的地方。那是他去买随机零件和五金的地方。但我告诉他别再去Swap-o-rama了。他同意他会找另一个地方买东西。
October 20, ICE got to my dad anyway. There's a text from my sister at 10:46 AM. ICE jumped out on Luis. I don't know who he's with. Luis is my sister's husband, and he works landscaping with my dad. I wrote, in all caps, WHERE? RIGHT NOW?
10月20日，移民局还是抓到了爸爸。我妹妹上午10:46发来短信。移民局在路易斯身上跳了出来。我不知道他和谁在一起。路易斯是我妹妹的丈夫，他跟我爸爸一起做景观设计。我用大写字母写道，在哪里？现在吗？
My mom messages me, La migra le llego a tu papa. My dad was shoveling someone's front lawn. When he looked up from his shovel, ICE was right there, the agents just a few feet away. Four cars stood in the middle of the street. One of the agents gripped his coworker's shoulder. Do you all have papers? They all said they did. They think that because no one tried to run, the agents let them continue working. So they did.
母亲给我发消息，La migra le llego a tu papa。爸爸当时在铲别人的前草坪。当他从铲子里抬起头时，移民局就在那儿，特工们离他只有几英尺远。四辆车站在街道中间。其中一个特工抓住同事的肩膀。你们都有证件吗？他们都说有。他们认为因为没人试图跑，特工就让他们继续工作了。所以他们真的继续工作了。
Going back through these messages now, I forgot how mad I got at my sister. I was alarmed. My sister seemed to move on quickly when she learned Luis and my dad were fine, which I found annoying. I kept asking her, where are they now? Are they together? Had they called the Rapid Response hotline to report ICE presence in the neighborhood, taken down license plate numbers or makes and models of the cars, information that could help other people at risk in the area?
现在翻看这些信息，我忘了自己当时对我妹妹有多生气。我感到很恐慌。我妹妹在得知路易斯和爸爸没事后似乎很快就走出来了，我发现这很令人恼火。我一直问她，他们现在在哪儿？他们在一起吗？他们有没有拨打快速反应热线报告社区里的移民局踪迹，记下车牌号码或车的品牌型号，这些信息可以帮助该地区其他面临风险的人？
My sister texts, I am telling you what I know. I am working, and they are working. I don't know how much communication you think I'm getting. My reply-- bro, this is a stop-work matter.
妹妹发短信，我正在告诉你我知道的。我在工作，他们也在工作。我不知道你觉得我能得到多少交流。我的回复——兄弟，这是一个停止工作的问题。
Five weeks into the operation, I saw a cheap flight out of Chicago to New York. I decided to take it, get away for a few days. Part of me felt guilty for leaving. Part of me felt like I should take the chance before it got worse. I spent the weekend with my friends in their living rooms, going on walks to dinner. Nothing about their lives had changed. It was unsettling.
行动开始五周后，我看到一张从芝加哥到纽约的廉价机票。我决定买了它，逃离几天。我的一部分因为离开而感到内疚。另一部分觉得在情况变糟之前我应该抓住机会。周末我和朋友们呆在他们的客厅里，散步去吃晚饭。他们的生活没有发生任何改变。这令人不安。
I told them how my body tenses up now when I hear a long car horn, how I look into car windows for masked agents, and that when we get a community alert reporting ICE on our phones, we think of every person we know who lives or works around there, how we text and call immediately, or show up, worried that the other person won't be there. I told them that I wasn't a special case, that this is what everyone I know feels.
我告诉他们我现在听到长汽车喇叭声时身体有多紧张，我是如何通过车窗寻找戴面具的特工的，当我们收到报告移民局在手机上的社区警报时，我们想到的每一个住在或在那儿工作的人，我们是如何立即发短信和打电话，或者出现，担心对方可能不在那儿。我告诉他们我不是个案，这是我认识的每个人都有的感觉。
Outside of Chicago, it was easier to answer the question, what it's like there? From outside, I could see how much we've adapted, how different everything is now, how extreme things have gotten. It's what I could see going back through my phone that this thing has bled into every single corner of our daily lives, our commutes, our jobs, our families, our dates and parties, and every single conversation.
在芝加哥之外，更容易回答这个问题，那里是什么样子的？从外面看，我能看到我们适应了多少，现在一切有多不同，事情变得有多极端。通过回顾我的手机，我能看到这件事已经蔓延到我们日常生活的每一个角落，我们的通勤、我们的工作、我们的家庭、我们的约会和派对，以及每一次谈话。
One last moment I found going through my phone, a text from my relative. She wanted me to know that ICE was at the corner by the pizzeria, where our cousin works. My cousin is the last one in my family who hasn't gotten his papers. I jumped off the train and took one going the other way. I ran down the street. If ICE was here, then I had just missed them.
我在手机里找到的最后一个瞬间，来自亲戚的短信。她想让我知道移民局在披萨店旁边的角落，我表弟工作的地方。我表弟是我家里最后一个还没拿到证件的人。我跳下火车，坐上了反方向的车。我跑下街。如果移民局在那儿，那我刚刚错过了他们。
My cousin had recently told his mom-- my aunt-- that if they ever came in and took him, it'd be all right with him. I'm not running, he'd said. Don't say that, she responded. She was upset that he had brought it up. My mother is upset by this, too. She told me the story over the phone. Let him have his peace, I told her. Perhaps he was just trying to prepare his mother and himself for something he couldn't control. Let him have that.
我表弟最近告诉他妈妈——我的阿姨——如果他们有一天进来把他带走，他觉得没关系。我不会跑的，他说。别这么说，她回应。她很难过他提这件事。我母亲也为此感到难过。她通过电话把故事讲给我听。让他保持他的平静吧，我告诉她。也许他只是试图为他和他的母亲准备一些他无法控制的事情。让他那样吧。
I stood outside the pizzeria that day, catching my breath. I peered through the glass until I caught a glimpse of him in the back of the kitchen. I waved and pretended I was only walking by. For once, I avoided the conversation completely, for my sake and for his. And I think we both felt relieved.
那天我站在披萨店外面，喘着气。我透过玻璃窥视，直到瞥见他在厨房后面。我挥了挥手，假装只是路过。有史以来第一次，为了我自己也为了他，我完全避免了谈话。我想我们都感到解脱。
That story was from Michelle Navarro. She's a writer and a producer on City Cast Chicago, a daily news podcast. It was edited by Chana Joffe-Walt.
那个故事来自米歇尔·纳瓦罗。她是每日新闻播客“City Cast Chicago”的撰稿人和制片人。它由查纳·乔夫-沃尔特编辑。
We just have a few minutes left in the show. We'll leave you with one last story. Act Three, Come, Mr. Cab Driver, Won't You Turn That Music Up? Our last story today comes from comedian Mohanad Elshieky, who found himself trapped in an uncomfortable mystery in the backseat of a cab.
节目还剩几分钟。我们以最后一个故事结束。第三幕，嘿，出租车司机，你不把音乐调大点吗？我们今天的最后一个故事来自喜剧演员莫哈纳德·埃尔希基，他发现自己被困在出租车后座的一个不舒服的谜团里。
Most recently, I decided I needed to work more on my small talk. So I was like, you know what? If I do take a Lyft or an Uber next time, I'm going to talk to that driver. I'm going to find a topic, and I'll run with it. And again, I took this man's car, and two minutes in, he starts playing music. And every song he played was something I really liked. So I was like, I got to let him know. So after each song, I would say, dude, this is a great song. Or I'd say, oh, wow, look at that. He's doing it again.
最近，我决定我需要更多地练习闲聊。所以我心想，你知道吗？如果下次我坐Lyft或Uber，我要和司机聊天。我要找个话题，然后进行下去。我又坐了这个男人的车，两分钟后，他开始播放音乐。他放的每一首歌都是我真正喜欢的。所以我心想，我得让他知道。所以每首歌之后，我都会说，伙计，这首歌真棒。或者我会说，哦，哇，看那个。他又来了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And I did that for a while, like, 20 minutes of me doing that. And that man did not respond to me once.
我这样做了好一阵子，大概20分钟吧。而那个男人一次也没理我。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Well, look, I'm a man on a mission. I'll get to him. But then, I swear to God, the music stops, and the thing he starts playing next was my standup comedy on the speakers. And I've never been more terrified in my life.
嗯，看，我是一个有任务的男人。我会搞定他的。但后来，我发誓向上帝保证，音乐停了，他接下来开始播放的东西竟然是音箱里的我的脱口秀喜剧。这是我一生中最恐怖的时刻。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Because I was like, I didn't even check if this was my car or not. I left the building, and I was like, this seems completely fine, and I got in. So I had to check in from the back, and I was like, hey, man. Hi. Do you know who this is? And he was like, what? I was like, the guy doing standup on the speakers, do you know who that is? And he was like, no. And I was like, well, it's me.
因为我想，我甚至没检查这到底是不是我的车。我离开大楼，想，这看起来完全没问题，然后我就进去了。所以我不得不从后面确认一下，我说，嘿，伙计。嗨。你知道这是谁吗？他说，什么？我说，音箱里在讲脱口秀的人，你知道那是谁吗？他说，不知道。我说，好吧，是我。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And he replied, well, that's good for you. I was like, oh, you're kidnapping me and gaslighting me? This is crazy.
他回答说，好吧，那对你来说是好事。我想，哦，你要绑架我并对我进行心理操控？这太疯狂了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And then I really thought something bad was about to happen. But then he drove me to the location I gave him, and I did say that out loud. I was like, oh, this is the location I gave you. And he was like, yeah, that's how this usually works.
然后我真的以为要发生什么坏事了。但他把我开到了我给他的地点，我大声说了出来。我说，哦，这就是我给你的地点。他说，是的，通常就是这么运作的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And I was like, dude, not to be rude or anything, but are you fucking with me? What is this? What is going on tonight? And he was like, what? And I was like, are there cameras around? Is this going to be on YouTube or something? What is going on? And he was like, sir, I just want you to leave my car.
我说，伙计，不是想冒犯什么的，但你是在玩我吗？这是什么？今晚怎么回事？他说，什么？我说，周围有摄像头吗？这是要上YouTube什么的吗？怎么回事？他说，先生，我只是想让你下车。
And I was like, oh, I'm the crazy person here. Oh, I see how it is. OK, I'm the weirdo. Just so you know, whatever this is, you got me. This will haunt me for the rest of my life. I will never forget you. Is that what you want? And then I started leaving the car. I took my backpack, and then I pulled my phone out of the charger.
我说，哦，我才是这里那个疯子。哦，我明白了。好吧，我是那个怪人。你只要知道，不管这是什么，你搞定我了。这将困扰我余生。我永远不会忘记你。这是你想要的吗？然后我开始下车。我拿了背包，然后把手机从充电器上拔了下来。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Which, as some of you know, doubles as an AUX cord sometimes. So it's been my phone connected to the speakers this whole time. And now there's a guy in New York City who thinks I'm an absolute psychopath.
众所周知，它有时也可以充当AUX线。所以这一路一直是我手机连着音箱。现在纽约市有一个男人认为我是个彻头彻尾的心理变态。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Because what happened was, I got into this man's car, this stranger's car, and I played my own music for 20 minutes. And then after each song that I played, I said, what a great song, man.
因为发生的事情是，我上了这个男人的车，这个陌生人的车，我放了自己的音乐20分钟。然后在我放的每首歌之后，我说，多棒的歌啊，伙计。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Oh, look at that. He's doing it again.
哦，看那个。他又来了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And then I played my own standup. And then I said, hey, man, excuse me, do you recognize the voice? Yeah, it's your boy right here. It is me. You're getting a good deal here. I'll tell you that. People usually pay to hear this voice. You're getting this for free. Are there cameras around?
然后我放了自己的脱口秀。然后我说，嘿，伙计，打扰一下，你认出这个声音了吗？是的，就是你眼前的这小伙子。就是我。你赚到了。我告诉你。人们通常付费听这个声音。你是免费得到的。周围有摄像头吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Is this going to be on YouTube, where it belongs? I surely hope so. I have not talked to people since. I think this is it for me. You guys have been an amazing crowd. Thank you so much. Have a great night.
这会出现在YouTube上，它属于那里吗？我真心希望如此。从那以后我就没和人说过话了。我想这就是我的终点。你们一直是一个很棒的观众。非常感谢。晚安。
[APPLAUSE, CHEERING]
[掌声，欢呼声]
Mohanad Elshieky is currently on tour. To see where he's performing next, check out his website, mohanadelshieky.com.
莫哈纳德·埃尔希基目前正在巡演。想看他接下来在哪里演出，请查看他的网站，mohanadelshieky.com。
["I GOTTA KNOW" BY THE TONETTES]
Well, this episode was produced by me. The other people who helped put together today's show include Phia Bennin, Michael Comite, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Suzanne Gaber, Sophie Gill, Tobin Low, Miki Meek, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Anthony Roman, Ryan Rumery, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Lilly Sullivan, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu.
嗯，这一集是由我制作的。参与制作今天节目的其他人包括菲亚·本宁、迈克尔·科米特、伊曼纽尔·佐齐、苏珊·加伯、索菲·吉尔、托宾·洛、米基·米克、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、斯托·尼尔森、纳迪亚·雷曼、玛丽莎·罗伯逊-泰克斯特、安东尼·罗曼、瑞安·鲁梅里、弗朗西斯·斯旺森、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、莉莉·沙利文、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor, David Kestenbaum. And our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks to Mark Fleming, Maria Román-Garcia, Belle Woods, Jen Tonks, Maria Stein-Marrison, Erin Mahollitz, and the second graders at Manitou School.
我们的执行编辑是莎拉·阿卜杜勒拉赫曼。高级编辑，大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。特别感谢马克·弗莱明、玛丽亚·罗曼-加西亚、贝尔·伍兹、詹·通克斯、玛丽亚·斯坦-马里森、艾琳·马霍利茨以及马尼图学校的二年级学生们。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. Please consider supporting the show as a This American Life Partner. You'll get bonus episodes-- I did one-- ad-free listening, and more. To join, go to thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners. That link is also in the show notes.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。请考虑支持该节目，成为《美国生活》的合作伙伴。你将获得奖励集——我做过一集——无广告收听等等。要加入，请前往thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners。该链接也在节目说明中。
Our episode, The Hand That Rocks the Gavel, was just selected by Apple as one of the Best Podcast Episodes of 2025. That episode is all about immigration judges who almost never speak to the press. If you missed it, check it out. It was released September 21.
我们那一集，“执槌之手”，刚刚被苹果选为2025年最佳播客集之一。那一集全是关于几乎从不对媒体发言的移民法官。如果你错过了，去看看吧。它是在9月21日发布的。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
《美国生活》通过PRX，公共广播交易所分发到公共广播电台。
Ira is out this week. But ever since I told him about the mystery box, he's been leaving me voice messages.
伊拉这周不在。但自从我告诉他关于神秘盒子之后，他一直在给我留语音信息。
(CHANTING) What is it? What is it? What is it?
（齐声喊）那是什么？那是什么？那是什么？
And to reward you all for enduring the mystery, we have a special guest to announce the contents of the box. Mr. Torey Malatia, will you tell the people what's in the box?
为了奖励你们大家忍受了谜团，我们请到了一位特别嘉宾来宣布盒子的内容。托里·马拉蒂亚先生，你能告诉大家盒子里是什么吗？
What's in the box? Your mama. Nah. It's a bottle of Advil.
盒子里是什么？你妈妈。别闹了。是一瓶Advil。
I'm Ike Sriskandarajah. Ira Glass will be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾克·斯里斯坎达拉贾。伊拉·格拉斯下周将带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
["I GOTTA KNOW" BY THE TONETTES]